we now know all about strong acids for
example hydrochloric acid in an aqueous
solution it's strong because it
disassociates completely into hydrogen
ions or hydronium molecules depending
how you want to view it and chloride
anions chloride anions and it's an acid
in the Arrhenius definition because it
once again this is an aqueous solution
in the arena's definition because it is
increasing the hydrogen concentration in
the water it's an acid in the
bronsted-lowry definition because it's
donating this thing is donating these
hydrogen protons and it's a Lewis acid
because you can kind of view this
hydrochloric acid it's by giving away
this it's taking these the chloride is
you can kind of say it's taking the the
electrons for itself so it's an electron
acceptor so that's another reason why
it's a why it's a Lewis acid but always
in every case it completely dissociates
so it's a strong acid now in that by
implication when I call this a strong
acid that must mean that there must be
things called weak acids weak weak acids
and you could probably guess what they
do they don't disassociate completely so
let's say you have hydrofluoric acid
hydrofluoric acid in an aqueous solution
it does disassociate somewhat so you are
going to have some hydrogen break off of
the fluorine molecule so I'm going to
hide Rajan ion and that's of course in
an aqueous solution now I did was doing
aqueous and blue aqueous solution and
then that's going to disassociate with
the fluoride the fluorine cation but
this is a weak acid so it's not just in
one direction it actually goes in both
so you can do this is an equilibrium
reaction and we know all about these now
which means that some of this goes in
that direction some of that goes in that
direction and both of these species
exist in the molecule and just as an
aside
you might wonder hey you know aren't
floor fluorine and chlorine they're both
halogens why is this a weak acid while
this is a strong one and this is just an
aside this is something I always used to
worry about wonder about so if you take
a hydrogen so in general hydrogen likes
to form bonds hydrogen remember alkali
metals alkali metals we included
everything below hydrogen right we
include all of these guys all of these
guys they have this one extra proton one
extra electron in their outer valence
shell so they just want to give it up
and they tend to be very willing to give
it up to these guys so if you have any
of these group any of these period two
and below with a halogen you normally
fall start form this ionic salt where
this guy gives away a protein a electron
then one of these guys take it and you
have an ionic compound hydrogen's a
little different it does have hydrogen
does have exactly one electron in its
outermost shell it just has one shell
but the first shell is interesting
because it's complete when it only has
two electrons these guys wouldn't have
been happy if you gave one electron to
these guys they need to get to eight so
they're not happy but if you give one
electron to hydrogen hydrogen is pretty
happy so when hydrogen forms bonds with
these guys here it doesn't just
completely give up the electron when
hydrogen forms bonds with with our
halogens over here it doesn't completely
give up the electron because Hyder says
hey if you give me some of the electron
then I get to two and then if you share
the electron you get to eight so it does
definitely like to bond with these guys
but doesn't give it completely up now
hydrochloric acid hydrobromic acid and
hydro I gotta Chi think I'm saying it
right these are all strong acids when
hydrogen bonds with any of these guys
which means it disassociates completely
in water but when hydrogen bonds with
fluorine it doesn't disassociate
completely in water and turn that the
reason why is fluorine is even more
electronegative so this bond between
hydrogen and fluorine so if you compare
hydrogen fluorine or hydrofluoric
hydrofluoric acid to hydrogen chloride
hydrofluoric hydrogen fluoride to
hydrogen chloride
this bond is much stronger not much
stronger I mean you can measure and kind
of the energy of the bond and we'll do
that eventually but this is a stronger
bond than this right here and
hydrobromic is even weaker so
hydrobromic let me draw it so this one
is a little bit weaker than that one and
then hydrobromic I'll draw it is just
one line right there it's like that so
these are easier to break so when you
put this in water hydrogen sees these
you know these water molecules that have
these extra that have these extra
electron pairs floating around and you
know this and it hog the electrons from
here so it has a partial negative
charges parts it's tempting for it to
disassociate with the water molecules
well in this case yeah it's tempting but
it still likes to be hanging around I
mean oxygen is very electronegative but
so is fluorine so it likes to hang
around with both so it kind of doesn't
completely disassociate so that's why
this one is a hydrofluoric acid is a
weak acid while the hydro all of the
other halogen ik acids are strong well
with that said the point of this isn't
to just you know look at the periodic
table let's figure out what the pH is
when I when I dissolve let's say I have
I mean let's say I have I have one point
five molar one point five molar of
hydrofluoric acid and I'm obviously I've
but by the definition since I've given
this as molarity I have it in some
solution and in this case I have it in
in an aqueous solution now you could
look it up but well actually I'll just
write so you know every equilibrium
reaction has some equilibrium constant
so we could write so the equilibrium
constant for this reaction under it in
green so the constant and well since
this is an acidic reaction we'll say
it's the equilibrium constant of this or
an acid constant however you want to say
it for hydrogen fluorine hydrofluoric
acid hydrofluoric acid it's equal to
well the products so it's the
concentration of your hydrogen ions
times your concentration of your
fluorine ions divided by your constant
of your hydrogen fluoride or
hydrofluoric acid so H FL and if you
look this up at 25 degrees Celsius at
roughly room temperature I believe that
is but let's say it is you get a
constant value here of 7 times 10 to the
minus fourth
so if I have 1.5 molar of hydrofluoric
acid can I figure out what the pH is
remember out I just essentially I want
to solve for this right here if I solved
for this in inventing then I know the
hydrogen concentration and then if I
take the negative log of that then I
know its pH so let's see if we can do
that so I'm throwing 1.5 molar on to
this side of the equation right but some
of its going to go and form that stuff
right so let's say X molar gets
disassociated so on this side let me see
what if I can do this
so if I throw so I'm throwing 1.5 molar
on this side some of it let's say X goes
X molar goes to that side right and so
let's say so if I have 1.5 molar on this
side once I'm in equilibrium X goes to
that side of the equation or X reacts to
form this stuff right here it
disassociates so once I'm in equilibrium
I'll have my concentration of hydrogen
fluoride will be 1.5 molar minus X and
what's my concentration of hydrogen well
if X molar or X moles of this the way
you can view disassociate then we have X
moles or X molar of that and we'll also
have X molar of that right what if one
of these disassociates and you get one
of that and one of that so these will be
the equilibrium concentrations and I
think you can you can smell some algebra
coming our way
so these are the equilibrium
concentrations let's see if we can solve
for X so I said so we know what the
equilibrium constant is it's seven times
10 to the minus fourth we know that the
final equilibrium concentration of our
hydrofluoric acid is the
original one point five molar we put in
- whatever disassociates into this stuff
up here and since X disassociated this
stuff here I have X molar of hydrogen
and I have X molar of fluoride and let's
say this is just pure algebra now let's
see if we can solve this so this is
equal to so let me I'm going to need
some space to do this so we get seven
times 10 to the minus four let's
multiply both sides times one point five
minus x times one point five minus X is
equal to x times X is equal to x squared
and then if we multiply C seven times 10
to the minus four times one point seven
times - one point five that's ten point
five right so we have ten point five
times 10 to the minus fourth that's that
times that minus seven times ten to the
minus fourth X is equal to x squared
this looks complicated but it's just a
quadratic equation and there's many
videos on that so let's just throw all
of this stuff onto the right hand side
because I like having a positive
coefficient here so you get so if I add
if I add subtract this two from both
sides and add this to both sides I get
zero is equal to x squared plus this so
plus seven times 10 to the minus fourth
X right I just add this to both sides so
it shows up on this side of the equation
which is right here
- this I'm subtracting this from both
sides equation so I get minus ten point
five times ten to the minus four now
this is just a this is a quadratic
equation here and just actually I'll
throw you a little you know we can solve
this quadratic equation we'll get the
answer in fact I'm about to solve it but
there is there is an approximation you
can do because if you look at this
quadratic equation this term here x
squared dominates this term right here
even when you have relatively small
values of X it dominates that term
so if chemists look at this and they say
hey you know what
this term is so much smaller if if this
term is so much smaller than then what's
going on here in a lot of cases you
might be able to just ignore it and then
the problem becomes very very simple
because if you ignore this term it's
still a quadratic if you don't have to
use the quadratic equation actually I'll
do that on the side right here I'll just
do it in a box because this isn't the
exact answer we're going to get us
pretty close to the exact answer so in
this make a nice little box here I'll
make a box so if we just ignore this
term then we'd have x squared x squared
is equal to this is equal to minus you
would add this to the other side so you
have plus ten point five times ten to
the minus four or X would be equal to
the square root of this X would be equal
to X would be equal to what see ten
point five and see you have to put the
exponent thing here so exponent four -
all right and I want to take the square
root so to the 0.5 power is equal to
point zero three two four so this is
point zero three two four so if we make
that simplifying assumption we've
essentially solved for our hydrogen
concentration right that was X this is X
so this is point zero three two four and
if we want to figure out the pH if we
want to figure out the pH we just take
the negative log of this so let's do
that so you take the log of it if you
just press log that's base ten so you
take the log and we want the negative of
that so you just say minus one point
four eight nine so about one point four
nine so it's a pH of one point four nine
but remember I did that using my little
simplifying assumption does not solve
the quadratic equation now let's solve
it just to kind of confirm in our heads
that we get the right answer because
that's actually the right way to get the
right answer so quadratic
Asian - B so X is going to be equal to
let me do it here X is equal to minus B
so minus seven times 10 to the minus
four plus or minus the square root of B
squared so B squared is 49 times 10 to
the minus eighth right 7 squared and
then 10 to the minus 4 squared and it
minus 4 times 2 is it minus 8 minus 4
times a which is 1 times C well C is a C
is a minus sign there we have this minus
sign so it becomes plus so 4 times 10
point five times 10 to the negative 4
that's what that's 42 times 10 to the
minus fourth power all of that over 2a a
is just 1 all of that over all of that
over 2 so let's see what we can get in
this square root right here so we have
and notice this is a very small number
compared to this this is really all we
should scare about with the square root
but let's just do it so 49 e8 negative +
so that's that small number plus 42
times 10 to the negative or to the 4
negative is equal to that so that's this
value right here and now we want to take
the square root so to the 0.5 power is
equal to 0.06 so so far we get X is X is
equal to I'll arbitrarily switch colors
-7 times 10 to the minus 4 plus or minus
0.06 for 8 all of that over 2 and this
is equal to and this would be clear we
can't say if we subtract it right here
we get a negative number this is a
smaller this is well this is already
negative so we subtracted we get a
negative number so let's just worry
about the plus sign because we can't
have a negative concentration so if we
add that to the
right there so we have 0.06
and then we have minus minus minus
actually let me make sure that I that
it's the minus is there so it's minus
seven times ten right I just want to
make sure I'm not making a mistake by
putting a minus there no it looks right
so let's see if we get a if we get so we
just do our math so we take this and we
subtract that so we have make sure so
it's minus I want make sure you can see
what I'm doing so we have minus 7e or
negative is equal to that and then we
have to divide by 2 divided by 2 is
equal to 0.03 2 so 0.032 and remember
this is our hydrogen concentration it's
also it's also going to be our
concentration of course are our fluorine
atoms but we don't care or ions we don't
care about that we just want to figure
out the pH so this is 0.03 2 which is
very close to our approximation before
but now we have the exact number so
let's take the log of it and then take
the minus of that so the log of that and
then you want to put a minus in front of
the log so the exact pH is right there
so our pH of hydrofluoric acid is equal
to one point four nine so once again
pretty low pH but notice this pH this is
one point five molar this is 1.5 1.5
molar of hydrofluoric acid while one
molar of hydrochloric acid Hanul even a
lower is even more acidic it had a pH of
0 so even though we put more acid here
we didn't get our pH as low as when we
used only one molar of hydrochloric acid
anyway see in the next video